do not it's that time you're gonna
apologize it's time for
ej's me
presented by no one come on
by sponsoring my sponsor 1989. you're
absolutely right
um so uh everybody got quite the kick
out of uh
that cognitive test that the president
took a few weeks ago right and
the internet just went wild what
remember the cognitive test were
part of it was remembering those five
things at the beginning when it was
person woman man camera tv
he saw that i didn't see oh come on how
did you know
oh how did you not see that but he's
given those five words and takes the
test and has to remember those five
words again and it was
person woman man camera tv he said you
get extra points if you remember them in
order
anyway we thought it would be fun to
test the chuckster in that very same way
oh see there so it's always fun to test
you yes because you went to auburn so
i'm
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
give you five words okay you forgot them
already catalog
those in your brain okay then i'm going
to ask you three questions and then i'm
going to ask you to repeat those five
words
okay okay here are your five words chuck
ready
boston shot clock denver
doughnut utah boston
shot clock denver utah okay
all right question number one four nba
cities start with the letter
m what are they miami
milwaukee minnesota
they got a blues down there it's getting
grizzly here memphis
there you go there you go here is here's
question number two
count these up in your head as we go how
many total z's
z's are used in the following words
pizza
zebra wizards
pajamas grizzlies
how many z's two
no wait no all together oh all together
oh
oh oh uh where's it have two z's either
no it has
one um pajamas
there's no z's in pajamas good i'm glad
you got that
anyway there were six total in the list
that i gave you here's question number
stupid can you
here's question number three speaking of
z's
if you were to go to sleep tonight at 3
30 in the morning
and sleep until 1 o'clock in the
afternoon how much sleep did you get
that's he knows he does that every day
how many hours
from 3 30 30 in the morning until one
o'clock in the afternoon
[Music]
uh eight and a half hours eight and a
half nine and a half
pounds okay no it's the same thing but
you do it every night and and now that
you're
already all right now that you're awake
chuck what are the five words
ballston shot clock good
i utah oh how to order but that's still
a word uh
come on man come on
wait time boston
utah uh you went out of order
don't tell him kid hey okay kenneth you
better not did we say pizza
no
you're missing the food that was what it
wasn't pizza you're missing a bad food
but it wasn't pizza
boston shot clock you're missing the bad
food
utah
[Laughter]
hey thomas
you're trying to make a fool out of me
well no you're doing a good job by
yourself
you know we don't need our help no
chick-fil-a
hey jeremy quit telling me stuff make me
guess wrong boston and doughnuts no
no boston shot clock denver
don't know you don't get donuts you're
uh yeah
you forget donuts and i gave you after
after 20 years your cognitive skills are
degrading here
i'm almost 60 years old i think i did
good three out of five
this is great honey anyway
that is gonna be a wrap for inside